he's the Marlins manager Don Mattingly
back on the program
a man look at the hair that's flowing
there Donny what else you know
quarantine huh looks good there can you
settle something because I somebody said
they gave me your age and I go I think
Don screwed up his age years ago that
you told you told the New York reporters
you were one age like but you were
actually a year older does that sound
right
you're younger oh you were you're
younger okay okay so you're relying
basically now it's really just messing
with them I told him one day I'm like
because I was like 23 or 22 you know
everybody wants to be younger right
number like I'm 41 and they're like no
you're 20 I'm like you got you got brief
proof right in those days you had
photocopy IDs a little wite-out reprint
it it put the new date and they bought
it
I mean it's New York reporters what do
you do but I think there was a tops
baseball card that has your birth date
as a wrong birth date it came out after
that do you have all your baseball cards
of the ones that you were on no I mean
I've seen like people's books and stuff
they'll show them to me and there are so
many cards and there's cards that you'd
like I had never seen these before right
so there's so many different cards how
much did you keep from your playing days
I was a little bit of a collector of
like guys that I liked like George Brett
you know ask for a bat the Jim Rice guys
that I liked and liked the way that
played that's kind of what I was a
collector of other people's you know my
mom was a collector I mean not a
collector but keeper right yeah his
first contract and and you know all
those type of things end up being in a
box and they're still in a box in our
storage unit somewhere did you get
anything from a pitcher you just
mentioned hitters you know I don't think
Oh y'all respect but no did you have a
picture though that you you respected
but you didn't like I think Roger was
one of the guys Clemens that you
respected the way he went about it I
remember a game in New York in his big
year well a lot of big years but I think
it was 86 yeah he was his stuff was off
the charts and faced him in New York and
I was pretty good fastball hitter I
really didn't feel like there's anybody
beat me with a fastball my whole career
and he's doing nothing but fast balls I
think and it was paint it was paint Cup
and in it was paint down in it was paint
Loewen away or paint up and away and
after like my I think it was my 30 bat
he was probably like a seventh or
something I said hey rich he was Gedman
catch and I said how about a breaking
ball but that day he was he was just
flat-out for me like he didn't miss a
spot with the fastball and that and you
have to respect the guy that came after
you like that and he knows you're a
fastball hitter and he's just bringing
cheese as if to say you think you're a
good fastball hitter I think I'm a
really good fastball thrower yeah those
are fun right there's a few times you
get guys like that to just go hey let's
go and you know that was Roger Roger was
he was tough like there was a I don't
know if I've told you this story before
we're in Boston and I think was Rick
Rhoden hit a couple guys early and after
the second guy I hear Rogers pitching
that day and I'm at first at first in
Boston's like eight feet away from their
dugout and I hear I'm gonna crack
somebody's helmet open and I know I
flicked Rogers talking right in my ear
and so I come up the next inning I don't
know if it was two outs nobody on or
first hitter and he threw one off the
backstop and I think he kind of stopped
all nonsense I don't know what that's
like if somebody homers in front of you
and you know that you're good somebody's
buzzed in the tower like what's that you
do anything wrong but what's that
feeling like when you go this is gonna
hurt
well you don't always know what the
homer like to be honest with you with
Tony LaRussa out in Oakland you knew
when you're gonna get it right and we
hit Big Mac one day and did mean she was
like three two count I think Dave
Lapointe got him in a head he'd been hit
like three times he ducked right into it
and I come up the next thing with two
outs and nobody on it Tony was like
first baseman for first base right so
Mac got and I'm up two outs nobody on
Dave Stewart on the mound who and it was
like like Stu came up and then it was
like instead of like keeping his going
towards the plate
he just went directly to me right back
and I was like oh that one hurt you kind
of knew it was coming that day the
unwritten rules of baseball Donnie is
anybody gonna write down the unwritten
rules of baseball they're probably too
many and then probably everybody's
interpretation of them right
it's just change it's changed a lot and
you know you're not gonna be one of
those guys that say old the old days
this it's just changed I think the game
is evolved it's just not gonna be that
way anymore it's you know you won't you
still have guys that play hard and get
after it and you know can do it in the
right way you still gotta play within
the rules of game that changed the rules
all the time it's just part of the
evolution of the game he's Don Mattingly
the Marlins manager you're gonna have a
hard time getting thrown out of games
given some of these rules that you can't
go out there and yell at the umpire says
this might actually be something
positive for you this could be my year
you know they're discouraging it I mean
the umpires are gonna be traveling with
us at times I mean you just can't do it
yeah so I this is my year that you don't
get thrown out so the bet is you don't
get thrown out for 60 games no I don't
think so this year I feel really good
I've been doing a lot of yoga and stuff
meditating a lot of namaste
going on so I mean I'm feeling calm
right now and I just feel like this is
the year I'm nervous about this season
and I'm not even involved in a daunting
so just as like what's the conversation
like at home with your wife about going
into this it was a little different
right because you know we're in Indiana
during the you know the quarantine and
they sent us like sent us how spring
training and you watched what was going
on in New York at the time so that was
kind of scary you thinking you know who
would fly into New York now and then
we're getting ready to fly into Miami
and Miami's like on a spike and you're
flying right into it I think it's
different I think you you have to take
care of yourself and there's a lot of
responsibilities for yourself or other
people's families team it's just it's
gonna be a different year dan there's
gonna be a lot to deal with and I think
the team that can kind of get past that
and after you do all the testing and do
all the stuff you're supposed to do who
can get down to baseball right in in do
it quick and that's what we're going to
be trying to do in spring that's what
every other team is going to be trying
to do they're all talking about the same
thing but the team that can actually do
it is gonna be the team I think that can
you know maybe make some noise in this
thing what do you think about the D H
and the National eHealth that will
affect how you manage well it makes it a
little easier a lot less decisions to
make as far as you know where you know
you're changing pitchers you know do you
have to double not double all that
you're just making pitching decisions so
that makes it a little less complicated
I don't say it make it easier but it
makes it a little less complicated I
think it helped our team but it helps
everybody
you know it's us we had a couple we had
like our lineups is getting better and
we we can use that spot to be able to
you know get an extra going to lineup
mix and match our lineup a little better
give me the guy in your lineup that
people should keep an eye on if this
season does get underway
is there somebody under the radar
well Brian Anderson I think everybody
with us has been under the
our Brian Anderson is a guy that's
that's been getting better and better as
a young player pretty good mechanics you
use the whole field pretty good
mentality got some power getting
stronger that's the kind of guy who can
continue to break out so he's a guy to
watch he son Diaz to me a guy with the
great swing at second base we just gotta
get his confidence where he starts to
believe that he's a big leaguer he's got
a really nice swing in there there are
other guys august jonathan villar fun to
watch came over from Baltimore hey Zeus
Eggman you are you're asking him to you
know hopefully have another big year
Corey Dickerson so we got a pretty good
little group going on if we can perform
I just figured out you look like Patrick
Swayze a little bit I don't know if you
know our old trainer gene Monahan yeah
he used to tell me that all the time you
know he was he would say that so I get a
little better at did you ever meet
Patrick Swayze I did not
I watched Roadhouse a lot I bet you I
feel like I'm lived Roadhouse I feel
like you lived Roadhouse at some point
in your life and once again you know no
spitting no sunflower seeds social
distancing you're still allowed to
adjust yourself right they're allowing
that right that's part of my new sign
set I got it I got it I got it little
play on words there there he is he's our
Patrick Swayze Donny great to talk to
you and good luck all right Don
Mattingly Marlins manager